(swoosh)
- Look.
(upbeat music)
Let's go.
Let's go!
Yeah!
You've got your perspective.
(upbeat music)
(cheering)
- [Man] I told him to be happy.
- [Woman] What perspective?
(gentle music)
- No test actually has
any impact on your life,
including the SATs.
In real life.
Not in the fake life that you and teachers
and parents have created.
So, if you actually believe what I said,
it gets really easy real fast.
The end.
The sooner you get out of being
fearful of tests and school,
the sooner you've started the process
of actually being a
successful human being.
(bell dings)
- [Man] How do I know if I find--
- Yeah we should clip that.
What?
- [Man] Yeah, that's good.
- Yeah, actually that's really true.
Let's keep this video going.
IGTV listen, I'm being serious right now.
Like, like.
If you are one that stresses tests
it means you care about
micro little things
and that will translate
into life in your 20s, 30s,
and 40s and you'll worry
about your boss' opinion
and you'll worry about getting a mortgage.
You're just gonna worry about very micro,
like goals which will then make you stress
and you'll just be in that
machine your whole life
then you're gonna care about your kids
being good at school and winning awards,
you're just gonna care
about the micro of life,
it's a huge vulnerability.
I'll say it one more time,
if you didn't catch it in the beginning.
The sooner you start not
stressing about tests in school
is the beginning of you actually
navigating a happier life.
(gentle music)
What do you want?
- [Man] So an intro like.
- Yep it's back, what
it is, what to expect.
- [Man] What do they expect
and then yeah, you nailed it.
- Hey guys it's Gary
Vee on a Monday morning,
still feeling the effects of an
incredible episode four of "Trash Talk."
If you haven't been following along
we're back after a long hiatus.
- [Justin] 20 bucks.
- 20 bucks.
Per or the pair?
- [Justin] The pair.
- No bullets?
- It's laser tag.
- Oh laser tag.
- Got them for laser tag.
Excellent.
(gentle music)
Alan get in on this.
- Awesome.
Cool, you got it.
(laughing)
I might just post this thing.
Get a little of this.
- [Camera Operator] What the light?
- Just me always going
through yellows is key.
(laughing)
Never stop at yellow.
Ever.
That's the difference
between an entrepreneur
and an employee.
- [D-Rock] Sometimes stop.
- Never.
Never.
You've got more time
than you think D-Rock.
The best part of that video
is the lights red as fuck
when I drive through it.
- (mumbling)
(laughing)
- That's what I'm posting.
Never stop at yellow.
- [Man] The worst at lights.
(laughing)
- Why?
- (mumbling)
- Yellow's caution.
You always have more time on the back end.
I literally put disclaimer,
this is life advice, not driving advice.
"Fact, good advice for the U.S.,
"but some people have been ticketed
"In third world countries
for crossing on yellow."
I'm like, what is the matter with you?
(laughing)
- [Man] Legendary.
- This is a good moment with
trying to open the car door.
- Was it?
Seriously?
- [D-Rock] I don't hear any static at all,
you can hear him.
- Which is huge.
- [D-Rock] Huge.
Where the fuck?
(laughing)
That was amazing.
- It's this button.
I can't find it on my car either.
- That's hilarious, what else you got?
- Just a couple other shots here.
This is just like a funny one
of you and Lou walking down the street.
♪ Follow the yellow brick road ♪
♪ Follow, follow, follow, follow, ♪
- It's like with a bin full.
- This is just so funny.
- I like the move of having Lou look it up
while you're at the garage sale.
- Oh, how funny was that?
D-rock let's try something.
Can you hear me?
Shake your head, amazing.
This is gonna be the new part
of "Trash Talk" invention episode four.
Can you have Little Lou
look up UNICEF mugs?
Cause I'm mic'd, cause I'm mic'd,
I'm literally like, I
realized it on this one,
this is the fourth time.
I'm like, "Hey, can you guys hear me?"
and they're like.
I'm like can you look up the.
- Yeah, I would do the same thing.
(upbeat music)
- The number one thing that
will separate the difference
of you crushing crushing something
or crushing crushing crushing something
is creating clarity around giving back.
- [Man] And I just retired from hockey,
and don't have a whole
lot of fucking money.
- That's good.
- [Man] So I need.
- And by the way there's
nothing wrong with that.
- [Man] Yeah.
- There's nothing wrong with
selling or doing whatever,
I don't know what the fuck you're doing.
I'm just saying, add an
hour a day or a week,
film it of you giving
advice to former athletes
and that's your content.
You'll be stunned how giving back
and not trying to convert.
One of the great things I do,
and I'm doing it at scale.
But find a place where
you are doing something
where you legitimately have no interest
in them doing business with you.
That's why everybody likes me.
I genuinely don't, I believe that 80%
of the audience that consumes me
inherently is a human,
because we're animals,
actually understands that I
don't want a dollar from them.
And by the way, when people are like,
"What have you done wrong?"
And I'm always like, "Fuck, I haven't."
Like I haven't really, I haven't,
I don't, I'm too much of an immigrant
and always have a nest egg
and never put myself in
a position to lose it all
because I don't care
enough about the money.
So I'm never gonna be like "that guy"
but the things I've done wrong
are the things I haven't done.
(gentle music)
The things I've done wrong are
the things I have not done.
- So missed opportunities?
- Missed opportunities that are hidden
that I'll never know if
what the fuck, I don't know.
What have I done wrong?
I should've done that TV show.
I should've gone on that
yacht with that billionaire.
I should've, like a million
things I've done wrong.
I mean, I should've said yes to Uber,
I mean the delta in my Uber
is 500 million dollars.
That's a lot of money.
And the only person I thanked in my book
besides my family.
It's not like some random guy pinched me,
it was my homie.
Because I bought a house
that I wasn't super liquid.
And there was a side project.
(gentle music)
So all my biggest mistakes
are the things I haven't done
not the things I've done.
That's what a real winner is.
I really believe that,
I really believe that.
Look.
(plastic rustling)
Open this real quick.
No.
Let's go.
Let's go!
- It's a refractor?
- Refractor, that's a monster card.
- That's a huge card.
- Huge card.
- I mean that's gigantic.
That's unreal.
- At a four ninety-nine.
- That's a huge card.
- Let's go.
I got a good one.
Yordan Alvarez, the guy I've been buying.
- No way.
- Yeah, I love this dude.
- Hey Gary.
Thank you so much for meeting with me.
- Yeah, happy to meet you bro.
- It's a pleasure.
How was your mother's day?
- Really good, thanks for asking.
- Good, good, awesome.
- What's going on with you?
- I really wanted to ask you a question.
- Please.
- But, the problem is,
I think I know,
- You know the answer.
- What the answer's already gonna be,
more until you're satisfied.
I'm not gonna use that word there,
but I kind of want to,
but I don't curse much,
it's not really my thing.
But I love you because
you're just all out there
and that's just you.
- And I love you for, that's right.
I'm so scared that people want to be me,
I just want them to be themselves
as much as I'm myself.
- I love that.
- And I love that about you.
I'm a big Christian, I won't curse.
I love that stuff, good for you.
- Thank you so much.
- You've got it completely
figured out on that front.
- Thank you so much.
- A lot of people start
trying to be like me
and it's not natural.
In the same way that when I was doing me,
it was super not accepted.
I was me 15 years ago, on the internet,
and cursing was not acceptable
the way it is now, to more people.
It's still not to plenty.
Is there anything I can help you with
before I run out to this flight?
- I would love to maybe just once a year,
just give you a call and say, "What's up?
"How's the family?
- I've got a better deal.
- "How you doing?"
- I want you to come here once a year
and work right out of here for the day.
- Okay, that's interesting.
- Because you'll pick
up a lot of information
through osmosis.
- Okay.
- Just by being in the
office for a full day.
I'm gonna do something even more fun.
Send me an email, I'm gonna run out now.
Are you coming with me?
- [Camera Operator]
Yeah, just for the ride.
- Send me an email, right now
and say thanks for the visit.
Do you want a picture
real quick before I leave?
- Yeah, I would appreciate it.
- Come back in a month.
- Okay.
- Send me an email.
- In a month?
- Yeah, in a month, I want
you to spend the day here.
- That's awesome.
- And just get osmosis.
- The day, you sure?
- Yeah, I'm positive.
- Good, I don't want to take
up too much of your time.
- You won't.
- Gary, thank you so much.
- You're welcome bro.
- I appreciate it.
- Have a great day.
(gentle music)
- Gary, I was gonna bring
them, but if you wanna.
- Bring them with me, you mean right now?
- Those you gotta fly with.
- Yeah, I was gonna put them in your bag.
- I think I can handle
it, thank you though.
- Awesome, have a good trip.
- Thanks bro.
Bro I got a D in speech.
I'm like, clearly one of the
great speakers of all time.
(gentle music)
Look I suck at everything else.
I'm sorry I think I'm a good speaker.
(gentle beat music)
Blows me away that people
just want to drive cynicism
into anything and everything.
I want to collect and flip cards.
I understand I have a lot of followers,
but I'm not big enough to
move any goddamn market
and I'm also like publicly sharing
the people I believe in.
I also even sold 10 Giannis
rookie cards at 300 a pop
and now they've moved to almost 600.
So I'm not gonna,
also about being right or wrong,
these are my hot take opinions.
Like I think De'Aaron Fox
is a very very very
good basketball player.
If he gets massively
hurt or under performs,
it doesn't matter what my opinion is.
I haven't seen a lot of this hate
and I'm sure it's happening
in community boards
and Facebook groups
and behind my back but,
I'm super pumped to be
flipping and buying and trading
and love being part of this community
and part of every community.
I was also part of this community
long before most of the,
not most, but a lot of
the people were even born.
So, I don't know who
gets to own a community,
but a lot of people feel like they do,
and I get that and I'm empathetic.
I hope we get to meet everybody,
or a ton of people in the hobby
at the national in Chicago.
Please come say hi.
Whether you think I'm
trying to manipulate,
listen, if I was trying to manipulate,
there's a lot of places where
I could make a lot more money
than sports cards.
I just love it.
And I've loved it for a very long time.
I've just been busy, now
finally I've enough scale
to be a little less busy.
Plus also believe, what a
lot of people have known,
which is the last two years,
the market has proven super good.
Like there's just a lot of
opportunities in the market.
I think the market's
got two to three years
of real growth, as long as
there's no economic downturn.
Because we all know cards
would be the first thing to go.
Anyway, I'm excited to
meet a lot of people.
I'm sure a lot of people
who're cynical or upset
will be less upset and cynical
once they get to know who I am as a human.
See ya.
I don't know if I'm gonna make it.
Still the same Av?
- [Avi] Yeah.
- Same thing?
- [Avi] Same thing 4:30.
- Avi, same time?
- [Avi] Same time.
- Okay, four minutes
away Av, I'm concerned.
See you, bye.
- [Avi] 4:32 now.
- Fuck.
I can't, these minutes matter.
Gate 42 is, I know where it is.
Pfft.
What's it say now Av?
- [Avi] About two minutes.
- I'm gonna be there in two minutes,
but like it's 4:30, it's at 5 p.m.
What is it 10 minutes
before they close the door?
- [Avi] Six minutes.
- Six what is it?
- [Avi] Six minutes prior.
- Oh six minutes?
You're sure Av?
- [Avi] Yep.
Awesome, I think I should make it.
- [Avi] They started boarding.
They start it now, right, 4:30?
Just see if there's a 6:00 flight.
(upbeat music)
I'm gonna fucking miss
this flight, goddamn it.
Fuck.
- (mumbling)
- Gonna miss this flight.
(laughing)
Fuck.
(upbeat music)